le premier ministre russe mir halamish
austin et est en déplacement sur l'île à
10 tours aux piles russe de l'archipel
des kouriles revendiquées par le japon
une visite qui provoque la colère la
correspondance à moscou d'antoine
clairement le premier ministre russe en
déplacement dans l'extrême orient du
pays a pour objectif de trouver des axes
de développement économique pour ces
territoires très éloignés de moscou et
ce déplacement dans les îles kouriles
n'a pas été très bien accueillie du côté
des autorités japonaises et pour cause
cet archipel se trouve au coeur d'un
différend territorial entre le japon et
la russie
et ce depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale la venue de michael mais justin
sur ce territoire disputé a donc
provoqué ce matin la convocation de
l'ambassadeur russe en poste à tokyo une
convocation au ministère japonais des
affaires étrangères et dans la foulée
toujours ce matin l'ambassadeur en poste
l'ambassadeur japonais en poste à moscou
a à son tour été convoqué au ministère
russe des affaires étrangères malgré
tout le kremlin se veut rassurant et
espère que ce différend ce litige
territorial trouvera bientôt une issue
heureuse et bien vous savez qu'un accord
de paix peut mettre un terme à cette
histoire
vous savez qu'au fil des gens de grands
efforts ont été déployés
y compris par le président poutine
pourtant revenir à cet accord de paix
sur cette voie il y a des difficultés
qui sont bien connus mais malgré elle ou
il existe du moins de la part de la
russie une forte volonté politique de
développer de bonnes relations avec
notre voisin oriental qu'elle au japon
il est vrai que depuis des années
maintenant les deux pays tentent de
tourner la page de ce différend
territorial le nouveau premier ministre
japonais yoshi des sugar déclaré
d'ailleurs en début d'année vouloir ne
pas transmettre cette dispute aux
générations futures car rappelons le à
l'heure actuelle la russie et le japon
n'ont toujours pas signé de traité de
paix à l'issue de la seconde guerre
mondiale et sont donc techniquement
encore en guerre